Toby is in HR which technically means he
works for corporate so he's really not a
part of our family
also he's divorced so he's really not a
part of his family Ryan cost Dunder
Mifflin hundreds of thousands of dollars
Michael Ryan David I don't care if Ryan
murdered his entire family he is like a
son to me you know what we're not going
to die of radon we're going to die
boredom yeah right and if I had a gun
with two bullets and I was in a room
with Hitler Bin Laden and Toby I would
shoot Toby twice
okay
well well well
how the turntables
good manager doesn't fire people he
hires people inspires people
right
and people will never go out of business
I am a victim of a hate crime
Stanley knows what I'm talking about
that's not what a hate crime is well I
hated it a lot okay I David here it is
My Philosophy is basically this and this
is something that I live by
and I always have and I always will
don't
ever
for any reason do anything to anyone for
any reason ever no matter what
no matter where
or who or who you are with
or or where you are going or
or where you've been
ever
for any reason whatsoever sometimes I'll
start a sentence and I don't even know
where it's going I just hope I find it
along the way
like an improv conversation
an improvisation
on Friday one of your employees attacked
another employee in your
own crime of
Pat not to describe Hawaii
everyone here is extremely gruntled
nobody should have to go to work
thinking
oh this is the place that I might die
today
that's what a hospital is for
an office
is for not dying
an office is a place to
live life to the fullest to the max to
an office is a place where dreams come
true
Webster's Dictionary defines wedding as
the fusing of two metals with a hot
torch
well you know something
I think you guys
are two metals
gold medals
in prison you are somebody's
oh and you you my friend would be the
bell of the ball don't drop the soap
don't drop the soap Michael please
is there no way we can get rid of him
not without cause Michael I have cause
it is because I hate him why I'm taking
responsibility
and it is up to me to get rid of the
curse that hit Meredith with my car
I'm not superstitious but I'm I am a
little stitches
would I rather be feared or loved
um easy both
I want people to be afraid of how much
they love me
do I need to be liked absolutely not I
like to be liked I enjoy being liked I
have to be liked
but it's not like this compulsive need
to be liked like my need to be praised
good trick is to pump to the tune of
Staying Alive by the Bee Gees do you
know that song yes yes I do I love that
song
first I was afraid I was petrified no
when I said before that I was king of
forwards you got to understand that I
don't come up with this stuff I just
forward it along
you wouldn't arrest a guy who's just
delivering drugs from one guy to another
why are you the way that you are
honestly every time I try to do
something fun or exciting you make it
not that way
I hate
so much about the things that you choose
to be
okay no no it's great I love working at
Dunder Mifflin a division of Taliban
Enterprises
Holly and I are like Romeo and Juliet
and this office is like the dragon they
kept them apart
an office
is as safe as the people in it and
sometimes those people can drive you to
do crazy things to show the dangers of
the office that's the danger I found
myself in today
I saved a life
my own
am I a hero
I really can't say but yes
um actually I'm sending Ryan on a top
secret mission
tell her what it is
updating emergency contacts
well is that really a priority is it a
priority oh I don't know
um what if there's a tornado Pam
people's legs are crushed under Rubble
please would you be so kind as to call
my wife no I can't because we don't have
any emergency contact information
because Pam said it wasn't a priority
think think with your head Pam okay well
she walks out you know what if we come
across somebody with no arms or legs do
we bother resuscitating them I mean what
kind of quality of life do we have there
I would want to live with no legs how
about no arms
no arms or legs is basically how you
exist right now Kevin you don't do
anything I love inside jokes
love to be a part of one someday
Dwight betrayed me once before
so this is his strike two
you know what they say
fool me once strike one
but fool me twice
strike three
it is St Patrick's Day and here in
Scranton that is a huge deal
is the closest that the Irish will ever
get to Christmas
what is it like being single I like it I
like
starting each day with a sense of
possibility
and I'm optimistic because every day I
get a little more desperate
and desperate situations yield the
quickest results
I feel like all my kids grew up and then
they married each other
it's every parent's dream
Ryan thanks
technology is the answer well guess what
I just drove my car into a lake you did
what I drove my car into a lake
well to be fair Jim James
Timothy
to be fair Timothy the that sounds weird
are you okay with being called Jim I am
all right since I am the boss I will
drive as well who wants shotgun you
can't be serious you ran a woman over
this morning everyone inside the car was
fine Stanley
guess what I have flaws what are they oh
I don't know I sing in the shower
sometimes I spend too much time
volunteering
occasionally I'll hit somebody with my
car
so sue me no don't
sue me that's the opposite of the point
that I am trying to make
my resolution I never want to make Holly
cry again
unless it's from laughing too hard
or making love too beautifully
unbelievable I do the nicest thing that
anyone's ever done for these people and
they freak out well happy birthday Jesus
sorry your party's so lame
don't make it harder than it has to be
Holly thinks that this relationship is
over well you know what I am not going
to give up that easy
I'm going to make this way harder than
it needs to be
in any cheating movie
the person getting cheated on is the
hero you're Ali Larter I'm Beyonce I Am
Beyonce always okay all right here we go
[Music]
more professional
I declare
bankruptcy
hey I just wanted you to know that you
can't just say the word bankruptcy and
expect anything to happen I didn't say
it I declared it
[Music]
it's Britney
okay